I think we're very alike in many ways
and I think that's what makes it work
and I think that's why people respond to
the fact that we got together we're like
except I can't sing dance Jennifer Lopez
and Alex Rodriguez are a match made in
heaven for many reasons but perhaps the
biggest their commitment to giving back
the couple's first project together a
telethon one voice so most live a
concert for disaster relief airing
October 14th on NBC Univision and
Telemundo we complement each other in a
beautiful way and I couldn't have asked
for a better partner in this I mean the
things that Alex did to help make this a
success for the people of Puerto Rico
and for all of Dez master relief has
been amazing for me especially to watch
Jennifer kind of lean into this too a
way that he know she was capable of I
mean here's someone who has like 20 job
and raising kids and being incredible
mother and the table she's calling
everybody in her contacts something that
she never does but it is so important
and it's so close to home for her let's
talk I'll go through that the contact
list I mean you get some unbelievably it
was fun to call you know Gwen Stefani or
Demi Lovato or Jamie Foxx or Leonardo or
any of these people Ellen DeGeneres and
go hey my full-time job is now Puerto
Rico and can you help me out and they I
can't even get the sentence out and
they're like yes what do you need it's
gonna be an amazing beautifully
heartfelt emotional exciting night so do
it in October 14
[Music]